i want to be your assistant
really
you hate it here so do you
i'll make sure you don't have to go to
any meetings
if anyone comes to see you i'll scare
them away
wait april if you had to choose between
these two ties
you're hired
i just figured i might as well get paid
for being here
ten months ago she was an intern who
could give a crap about local government
now
she's our newest employee to april
cheerios yay jerry come and celebrate
no thanks well everybody let's get back
to work
where are you going
i want to talk to ryan about the size of
my desk
jerry
you have to schedule an appointment
okay how about now ron's not here he's
right there i i can see him i'll let you
know when he's available
and a girl
detectives i see we got eight recruits
for the junior police program
outstanding thank you sir but as
important as your praise is to me it
should actually go to gina she's the one
that got through to the kids yes i am
amazing and i only asked for one thing
in repayment
a 600 raise or i could give you a zero
percent raise and make you my personal
assistant which is what i'm doing i
think you have hidden talents which will
make you surprisingly good at the job no
i have no talents you start monday
ugh
constantly getting hulk's approval is
the worst yes i can only imagine
you should go yes yes final walkthrough
mm-hmm sign the papers at the condo you
have your lawyer there uh i don't need
one can i be your representative
i think i should be there no no i'm good
i can make sure things are up to go
dwight please i'm always the guy that
you rely on at work well this isn't
about work this is closing on a condo
it's completely personal so you're
taking a personal day
except that this is about my living
arrangement and as boss i need to have a
living arrangement
in order to do work please
i'll make you proud
okay fine yes you can come yes as your
representative has my associate same
thing no it is not i have been michael's
number two guy for about five years and
we make a great team we're like one of
those classic famous teams he's like
mozart and i'm like
mozart's friend
no
i'm like butch cassidy
and michael is like
mozart
you try and hurt mozart
you're gonna get a bullet in your head
courtesy of butch cassidy i need to find
someone to fill in for april
now i know i'm not gonna find someone
who's both aggressively mean
and apathetic
april really is the whole package i know
that
every one of you
give me everything you had
and i will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
me more
see
dismissed
sir
i'm coming with you thank you gina i'm
also coming not necessary
nice
all done
what's wrong michael it's like a gum in
my hair
you do this
just
stinks don't touch it please don't touch
it you've got a ton of dandruff okay let
me be how did you get gum in your hair i
was walking in and i noticed something
shiny under stanley's car and i got
under sea what it was and i messed up my
hair all for a stupid piece of tin foil
but best case scenario you thought it
was a quarter kill me
right now we have peanut butter in the
kitchen
i don't feel like peanut butter give me
an ice cream sandwich nope not for you
it's for your hair and it is nine a.m
no dwight not the good peanut butter
people are gonna get mad hey hey hey
this is my hair we're talking about
smells good
tastes good too oh dom that's disgusting
wow a lot of calories
well just don't leave it on too long
keep massaging please
oh yeah that's nice
parks and rack
confirming
what
that's not possible
oh no
hey good morning why are there six
people outside who say they're waiting
to meet with me so you know how you love
me because you haven't had a single
meeting with anyone since i became your
assistant that's because
every time someone calls and requests a
meeting with you i always schedule it
for march 31st
why because i didn't think march 31st
existed
30 days has september april march and
november june and november
today is march 31st i know
so then how many meetings do i have
today
93
oh
okay okay well
you know what to do
right
to me
this situation is a blood-soaked
nightmarish hellscape
however to leslie knope oh how fun
yay i thought i was having this meeting
with ron swanson i'm afraid that ron
swanson's
currently dead oh i'm his daughter april
swanson and it's his last wish that i
have this meeting with you there's no
way this ordinance goes through there's
too much red tape this gridlock draws me
nuts tell me about it yeah i think
you're gonna have to make an end run you
know um go right to the commissioner on
this one you know what i hadn't thought
of that that is a really great idea yeah
i'm gonna do that okay
your last resort is probably gonna be
city council good luck there
my thoughts exactly i have no idea what
i was saying
how many more meetings twenty
april was supposed to be the moat that
kept the citizen barbarians away from
swanson castle instead she blew up the
castle and stabbed me in the face
i hired you to do one thing
just one
i don't care that you text all day and
sleep at your desk in fact i encourage
it but only because you were doing that
one thing
keeping this crap
off my desk
give me five minutes before the next one
we're here so i can activate the holy
network of administrative assistants
acronym pinna
we high-level assistants keep track of
what's going on with all the bosses
jealous amy yeah i tap that
network i tap that network that's a
thing people say yeah yeah
members of the office hear ye
that means ye plop
plop
still we owe andy that much yeah
absolutely we do am i right people
fine today we will be testing candidates
for the position of assistant to the
assistant to the regional manager ah
heck yeah nice you'll always have the
upper hand when you've got a good
arm trademark pending this is not an
excuse to blow off work doing
carnival-like activities sure every
participant will be getting a corn dog
but that's for fueling only no savoring
oh what an honor god i envy them he
envies you
you don't need to repeat right now all
right what i'm saying by two o'clock
dwight will choose himself to be
assistant to his own assistant
me a good assistant knows what their
superior is thinking before they even
think it meredith what number am i
thinking of right now uh
two
985 trillion seventeen not even close
meredith come on put animal on my
picturing a horse ooh the exact opposite
actually what's the opposite of a horse
seahorse
whoa
how did you know that i was gonna say
that
i'm uncanny challenge number two
protocol clerk yeah do you want a corn
dog i would love a corn dog we'll see
you are an assistant who's just gotten a
phone message i am in a meeting with
dwight robert dunder and his niece uh-oh
look who came to join us the turkish
ambassador to armenia yuri slovak who by
the way is extremely embarrassed about
the size of his nose go ahead and read
that phone message
mr halpert your wife called to find out
how your meeting with yuri big nose went
no no no no you don't read it aloud like
that
god besides the whole thing is a trick
question there's no turkish ambassador
to armenia two countries don't have
diplomatic relations
uncanny
oh god nice she's through the green
everybody here comes yellow no no no
real doozy phyllis seriously
look at that form god this is pathetic
the boss needs his coffee
[Applause]
who you are sir here's a copy i'm a skin
ow
burns
all right this whole search for the
assistant thing
none of these people are good enough i
know
what i'm about to say makes no logical
sense and yet
it might be the most logical thing i've
ever said jim this is gonna come as no
surprise but i know exactly what you
were gonna say
the only possible assistant to my
assistant is
me
you